[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual político sobre
el papel tendrían que ser dos grandes
aliados algo así como el bad bank y el
robin o el fruto y sam de la política
internacional giro y todo la ciudad te
viene
[Música]
veréis me explicó japón y corea del sur
son países relativamente libres en un
entorno geopolítico donde esta condición
no es habitual comparten socios se
enfrentan a las mismas amenazas y tienen
fuertes lazos económicos os parece poco
[Música]
japón y corea del sur tienen el mismo
aliado estratégico eeuu un país que
tiene desplegados entre los dos países
casi 80.000 soldados vamos que es
prácticamente un ejército completo
además los dos países se enfrentan a los
mismos retos estratégicos
fundamentalmente al envejecimiento a
corea del norte y al creciente peso
económico político y militar de china
pero eso no es todo además con un
comercio bilateral que anualmente supera
los 80 mil millones de dólares y un
tránsito de más de 10 millones de
turistas las economías de japón y corea
del sur están muy relacionadas
[Música]
ya lo veis la teoría nos dice que
tendríamos que estar ante todos buenos
amigos y ojo porque juntos corea del sur
y japón forman un bloque mucho más
fuerte de lo que podríais imaginar
hablamos de un bloque con 177 millones
de habitantes una economía combinada de
más de 65 billones de dólares una
producción industrial que duplica la
alemana o multiplica por cinco la de
francia y con más de 90 mil millones de
dólares tienen el tercer mayor
presupuesto militar de todo el planeta
tan sólo por detrás de eeuu y china
vamos que si tuvierais que trabajar como
consultores de estos dos gobiernos
seguramente les recomendaría jce
estrechar lazos y trabajar codo con codo
verdad espera hace un momento porque una
cosa es la teoría y otra muy distinta a
la realidad lo cierto es que japón y
corea del sur- se llevan fatal y eso es
lo que explica noticias como esta un
incidente naval ocasiona un aumento de
tensión entre corea del sur y japón
olvídense de corea del norte japón
versus corea del sur el próximo
enfrentamiento en asia y sabéis que
ahora más que nunca el tema está que
arde queréis una prueba atentos según un
estudio realizado en junio de 2019 ni
más ni menos que el 74% de los japoneses
desconfían de los surcoreanos y por el
otro lado las cosas no son mucho mejores
el 75% de los surcoreanos no se fía de
los japoneses
pero ahí no queda todo a principios de
julio de 2019 el gobierno de japón
desató una especie de guerra comercial
contra corea del sur
en concreto restringió las exportaciones
de tres productos clave para la
industria surcoreana la poliamida
fluorada el fluoruro de hidrógeno y los
fotoprotectores
puede que no hayas escuchado nunca nada
sobre ellos pero hablamos de tres
productos químicos imprescindibles para
fabricar semiconductores y las pantallas
de los smartphones dos componentes de
los que corea del sur es uno de los
mayores fabricantes y exportadores del
mundo de hecho podríamos decir que los
semiconductores son algo así como el
petróleo surcoreano korea del sur es el
líder mundial en la fabricación de chips
y japón es el líder mundial en la
fabricación de los materiales clave para
producir chips anki y un vicepresidente
de la asociación de la industria de
semiconductores de korea y ahí no
termina todo a comienzos del mes de
agosto japón anunció nuevas
restricciones que pueden no ser las
últimas pero amigos antes de continuar
creo que debemos hacernos algunas
preguntas qué diantres está pasando
porque japón desata semejante conflicto
con uno de sus mayores socios
comerciales qué consecuencias puede
tener atentos
[Música]
y la reconciliación que nunca llega
para comprender toda esta historia
tenemos que remontarnos hasta principios
del siglo 20
desde el año 1910 hasta el final de la
segunda guerra mundial en 1945 coria fue
una colonia de japón y que no fueron
años precisamente felices para los
coreanos amigos el imperio de japón
dirigió corea con mano de hierro la
represión fue dura durísima se
cometieron una enorme cantidad de
crímenes y muchas tierras fueron de
facto expropiadas para que os hagáis una
idea mientras el pueblo surcoreano
pasaba hambre gran parte de la
producción agrícola de korea era enviada
al propio japón y eso no es todo
además durante la ocupación japonesa
cientos de miles de surcoreanos fueron
reclutados a la fuerza para trabajar en
condiciones brutales de semiesclavitud
en la industria y en las minas japonesas
la universidad de stanford estima que
fueron más de 700.000 surcoreanos
y si pensáis que esto es terrible espera
un momento porque aún podemos encontrar
cosas peores durante la segunda guerra
mundial decenas y decenas de miles de
mujeres fueron obligadas a ejercer el
oficio más antiguo del mundo para
satisfacer a los soldados japoneses se
calcula que fueron entre 50.000 y
200.000 las mujeres víctimas de esta
atrocidad
amigos todo esto es lo que explica que
77 décadas después japón y corea del sur
continuó empleándose por lo que
significó la ocupación
un gobierno regional cercano de seúl
está pidiendo que todos los productos
escolares de fabricación japonesa tengan
una etiqueta que diga que fueron hechos
por criminales de guerra por supuesto
desde que corea del sur- recorrerá su
independencia en el año 1945 han sido
muchos los intentos para reconciliarse y
pasar página' los dos más importantes se
produjeron en 1965 y en 2015 y sabéis
que ambos tuvieron el mismo resultado
[Música]
en 1965 cuando corea del sur era una
dictadura dirigida por park chung y los
dos países llegaron a un acuerdo para
poner punto y final a las disputas japón
asumió su responsabilidad y se
comprometió a pagar al gobierno
surcoreano el equivalente a unos 2.400
millones de dólares actuales como
compensación y otros 1.600 millones en
préstamos con bajos intereses
[Música]
sin embargo en el año 2012 la corte
suprema de corea del sur reconoció el
derecho de las víctimas a obtener una
compensación individual ojo no del
gobierno japonés sino de las empresas
japonesas que estuvieron involucradas en
los casos de trabajo forzoso
[Música]
el fallo de la corte suprema de corea
del sur abrió la puerta a que en el año
las empresas nippon steel mitsubishi
heavy industries y lanas y fuji cosi
corporation fueran condenadas a pagar
entre 70.000 y 90.000 dólares a cada una
de las dos docenas de víctimas que
habían reclamado ante la justicia
ojo porque aquí está la clave a ellas oa
sus parientes vivos porque claro algunas
ya habían fallecido os imagináis que
ocurriese lo mismo con el resto de
trabajadores forzosos que sus familias
pudieran reclamar hoy una indemnización
estaríamos hablando de miles decenas de
miles de millones de dólares que por
supuesto japón no tiene ninguna
intención de pagar entre otras cosas
porque desde su punto de vista todo este
tema se solventó con el acuerdo de 1965
[Música]
por otro lado en 2015 los dos gobiernos
acordaron que japón crearía un fondo de
unos 9 millones de dólares para
compensar a las mujeres que fueron
víctimas de la esclavitud durante la
segunda guerra mundial pues sabéis que
este acuerdo pues tampoco valió para
nada porque atentos
[Música]
estrategia del fuego más grande la
economía de corea del sur no atraviesa
hoy por sus mejores momentos es algo de
lo que ya os hemos hablado aquí en
visual político en un vídeo que os dejo
en la descripción amigos desde que mucho
y llegó al poder las cosas se han ido
torciendo casi tan rápido como
desaparecen las fotos de snap chat y por
supuesto detrás de la economía ha ido la
propia popularidad del presidente
según las encuestas la aprobación del
presidente mundial cayó desde el 83 por
ciento que tenía en mayo de 2018 hasta
el 45% un año más tarde y no sólo eso
además en un momento en el que los
asuntos económicos cobran cada vez más
peso la aprobación a la gestión
económica del líder surcoreano se ha
desplomado hasta el 30 por ciento
y queridos amigos de visual político es
alguna pregunta que haces cuando tienes
un fuego enorme pero quieres que la
gente mire para otro lado puedes montar
otro fuego aún más grande a ver no lo
digo yo es una de las recetas más
antiguas de la política
[Música]
pues eso es exactamente lo que parece
estar haciendo mucho echar gasolina al
fuego que por otra parte lo cierto es
que tampoco es algo que le haya costado
mucho veréis desde que llegó al poder en
el año 2017 ha tenido a japón siempre en
el punto de mira de hecho una de sus
primeras acciones fue anunciar
unilateralmente y con efecto retroactivo
la suspensión del acuerdo del año 2015 y
schümann sigue durante el último año nos
hemos encontrado con declaraciones
políticas cada vez más polémicas la
inteligencia surcoreana ha empezado a
reducir la información que comparte con
japón en diciembre de 2018 según fuentes
niponas una fragata surcoreana fijó su
radar de tiros sobre un avión japonés
poco después seúl impidió el uso de sus
puertos por parte de los barcos de las
fuerzas de defensa de japón e incluso a
comienzos de 2019 hemos visto un boicot
a la compra de productos japoneses
instigado por el propio gobierno
surcoreano
vamos que si lo que buscas pelea parece
que el presidente surcoreano no podría
estar haciendo lo mejor actualmente la
relación bilateral es tan mala como en
los peores momentos y continúa
deteriorándose an jing hay profesora de
relaciones internacionales en la
universidad de corea el caso amigos es
que parece que mucho y no pensaba que
japón iba a responder con tanta
contundencia o tal vez sí
trump abre la puerta a japón la cruza
os lo hemos dicho muchas veces en visual
político donald trump abrió la veda fue
todo un precursor utilizar el comercio
como arma arrojadiza las negociaciones
políticas internacionales
[Música]
ahora japón ha ido un paso más allá
utilizar la guerra comercial para
castigar a un aliado japonés está harto
y shinzo abe está hasta las narices
considera que el tema de corea del sur y
las rencillas pendientes ha ido
demasiado lejos el acuerdo de 1965 las
disculpas del 90 del 91 el acuerdo de
2015 tokio no está dispuesto a hacer más
concesiones
claro que para ser justos tampoco ayuda
pues que el mismo primer ministro sea un
revisionista convencido os hemos hablado
de ello hace muy poquito en este canal
el caso amigos es que a comienzos de
julio el gobierno japonés decidió
castigar a corea con la restricción de
los tres componentes que hemos visto la
poliamida fluorada el fluoruro de
hidrógeno y los fotoprotectores
hablamos de una medida que de no
revertirse pronto podría causar grandes
problemas a gigantes surcoreanos como
samsung o sky y knicks dos de los
mayores productores de semiconductores
del mundo pero eso no es todo a
principios del mes de agosto el gobierno
de japón comunicó su decisión de sacar a
corea del sur de su lista blanca de 27
países con estatus comercial preferente
es decir países que pueden comprar
libremente sin ninguna restricción la
tecnología y la mayor parte de productos
japoneses de esta forma para comprar
prácticamente cualquier producto excepto
alimentos y madera las empresas
surcoreanas tendrán que cumplir un
proceso de aprobación por parte del
gobierno japonés lo que no sólo implica
más burocracia y costes de importación
sino sobre todo que ahora el gobierno
japonés pasa a tener la sartén por el
mango puede vetar a su antojo cualquier
venta a corea del sur
[Música]
esto amigos es algo que daban las
profundas relaciones comerciales entre
los dos países puede llegar a suponer un
duro un durísimo golpe para corea
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ojo no solo para corear también para
japón que tiene un superávit comercial
con su vecino de más de 20 mil millones
de dólares
y
ahora bien la excusa oficial pues que
corea del sur no garantiza que todas las
exportaciones de productos y tecnología
con posible uso militar no lleguen a
corea del norte
y es que por ejemplo productos como el
fluoruro de hidrógeno no solo se
utilizan para producir semiconductores
sino también para el enriquecimiento de
uranio la fabricación de gas sarín por
supuesto amigos esto no parece más que
una excusa el motivo real es la
interminable controversia en torno al
dichoso pasado colonial las acusaciones
japonesas son muy serias pero no han
proporcionado evidencia de ninguna
conclusión entre corea del sur y corea
del norte hasta el momento celine para
jon experta en japón en el instituto
francés de relaciones internacionales
claro que llegados a este punto amigos
la pregunta que podemos hacer no sé si
tiene sentido recurrir a la guerra
comercial como arma arrojadiza en
política exterior pues lo cierto es que
la experiencia y la evidencia nos dice
que no
veréis ahora el gobierno de corea del
sur no sólo ha respondido con sanciones
propias sino que también está poniendo
sobre la mesa mucho pero que mucho
dinero para reducir su dependencia de
las empresas japonesas
es algo parecido a lo que ocurrió con
china en 2011 en aquel momento el
gobierno chino restringió la venta de
tierras raras a japón y que hicieron los
japoneses puedes invertir en sus propias
minas al final
la cuota de mercado de china se redujo
al tiempo que a los contribuyentes
japoneses les tocó pagar el pato
[Música]
es decir un resultado malo para todos
así que es posible que en esta ocasión a
shinzo abe también le salga el tiro por
la culata en fin amigos lo que se espera
es que japón y korea tarde o temprano
regresen al punto de partida y de esa
forma pues continúe esta interminable
espiral de agravio de momento japón ya
ha concedido un permiso para la venta de
fotos resistentes a samsung eso sí a
partir de ahora el proceso será más
lento y el gobierno japonés tendrá
siempre en su mano decidir si aprueba o
no la venta de forma totalmente
arbitraria por eso si es probable que
las cosas vuelvan en cierto modo a su
cauce sin embargo de aquí en adelante
habrá muchos matices y muchas tensiones
pero sabéis que sería bueno para todos
que zanjarán de una vez este asunto han
pasado 70 años ya vale
[Música]
el bloque
amigos una estrecha alianza entre corea
del sur y japón sería algo muy bueno
formarían un bloque económico y político
con mucha muchísima influencia ahí está
por ejemplo el acuerdo de libre comercio
con china que japón y corea del sur
están negociando conjuntamente bueno
ahora como un chelín todo esto se ha
frenado para crear un espacio de
comercio más grande y profundo eso sería
bueno para todos
a nivel político serían algo así como un
faro en una de las zonas del mundo más
repletas de dictaduras y a nivel militar
serían capaces de ser todo un contrapeso
a china incluso más allá del ejército
que eeuu tiene desplegado en estos
países
pero por supuesto para lograr todo esto
es esencial necesario imprescindible que
los dos gobiernos lleguen a un acuerdo
que de una vez por todas les permita
dejar atrás el pasado y centrarse en el
futuro amigos estoy seguro que ahora
entendéis mucho pero que muchísimo mejor
que vía entres está ocurriendo entre
corea del sur y japón así que bueno
espero que este vídeo os haya resultado
interesante si ha sido así ya sabéis no
olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
abisal político como que aún no lo
habéis hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]